good evening i'm lieutenant ray spencer
i'm the homicide lieutenant with the las
vegas metropolitan police department i'm
out here this evening to brief you on a
homicide investigation that we are
conducting in the 9300 block of
gilchrist avenue which is near the
intersection of osa blanca and sky
canyon in the far northwest part of the
valley the details that i have right now
are very preliminary but at around 7 pm
this evening metro police responded on
report of a male who had been shot
medical personnel and officers arrived
and pronounced that male who was a white
male in his late 20s deceased
the details that we have is that there
were several individuals four people
who were inside of an apartment directly
behind me
at some point the four were hanging out
socializing this evening and one of the
males had picked up a handgun and
started playing with the handgun
dear while he was playing with the
handgun the handgun get went off and
shot the victim
at that point we received two 9-1-1
calls one from the person who fired the
shot and another from another person
inside the apartment reporting that the
shooting had occurred
at this point we are interviewing all
the parties involved and it is still
very early on in the investigation so
with that i'll take a couple questions
but again very early on
at this point how many shots went off
when he was playing with the gun and how
many how many struck
him so right now we believe it was one
fired and one struck him so that's at
this point but again we're still in the
process of obtaining a search warrant to
validate some of the details that have
been provided to us in the early part of
the investigation once we have the
search warrant obtained we'll be able to
answer that specifically is the person
that fired the gun facing charges at all
right now it's still too early on in the
investigation to answer that so it's
again a lot of moving parts at this
point in people to interview do you have
the approximate age of the person who
shot the fire the shot yeah everybody
involved is are is a white male in their
late 20s what would your message to
people who are maybe a little concerned
about this this is a pretty quiet area
things like this don't really happen in
this area too often well my main message
right now is
anybody who is holding a firearm needs
to treat that firearm like it is loaded
it is the first rule of any firearm
safety that
one of the rules of firearm safety is
any gun that you are holding is
potentially
a loaded weapon so
especially when you're playing with a
handgun in a setting like this this is a
tragic outcome to a situation that is
completely avoidable and do you know the
type of gun that was
used
we believe it's a handgun and did they
all live in this apartment or do we know
a couple people lived in the apartment
we believed there was a couple people
that were visiting
right thank you guys i appreciate it